hello everyone my name is shomabrata pal
i am currently a postdoctoral researcher
at google research
today i am going to speak about support
recovery in universal one bit compress
sensing this is a joint work with my phd
advisor arya masumdar
in the present world
data is ubiquitous and the amount of big
data is increasing exponentially it is a
significant challenge to store this data
efficiently
and reconstruct it
since most data sets such as raw images
or raw audio signals have a large size
it is difficult to design efficient
algorithms without any structural
assumptions
luckily for us in practice
most signals are sparse in some domain
that is we can use some kind of basis
transform such as a wavelet transform or
a fourier transform to represent
the signal as a sparse vector
where most of the entries are zero
so let's look at an example
it turns out that although most images
look random and are hard to compress
most signals that we care about such as
these images below are highly structured
and they're they are sparse after using
the basis transform such as the wavelet
transform or the fourier transform
and henceforth we will assume that this
change of basis has been pre-applied to
make the data sparse
so let's be a bit more mathematically
rigorous
suppose we have a
signal vector
which is n dimensional and we will
denote it by
the x
and we will assume that each signal is
parts that is it has at most k nonzero
elements
that is again the l0 norm of x is at
most key
and we will call the set of non-zero
indices of
the vector x
as the support
and
we will denote the support by sub of x
and it turns out that
such sparse high dimensional signals can
be compressed and reconstructed by using
quantized linear measurements where the
number of measurements is
much smaller than the size of the latent
dimensions dimension space which is n
in this paper we look at an extreme
quantization setting known as the one
bit compressed sensing
here we will use science of the linear
measurements to compress and reconstruct
a sparse factor
so we will begin by introducing the sine
function which takes as input a real
number x
and returns 1 if x is positive and
returns 0 if x is 0 and minus 1 if x is
less than 0.
so we will extend this notation so sine
of a vector will be the sign of each
entry of the vector
okay
so now the one bit compression strategy
works in the following way we take
linear measurements of the signal vector
and only store
its sign
and our goal is to reconstruct the
signal from the stored sign vector
okay so in the reconstruction step we
have a measurement matrix a
which has m rows where m is much smaller
than the dimension n
an unknown signal vector x which is
known to be k sparse
and we have an observed vector y which
is sine of a x
and therefore the entries of y only
contains the elements 1 minus 1 0 and so
on
and our goal is to reconstruct the
unknown signal vector x
this problem has applications in many
domains such as photography holography
and facial
recognition and an important property
that we care about in this
problem is universality the measurement
matrix that we design must work for all
n-dimensional signal vectors
that are sparse
and this is especially important in
applications such as photography
where we must have a single compressing
algorithm or strategy that is
incorporated into the software of a
camera
so that
we can only use
one algorithm for compressing
whatever image that is taken by the
camera
and mathematically our objective in this
setting can be
twofold first of all we can go after
signal reconstruction where our goal is
to reconstruct the unknown signal x
note that we cannot
recover the magnitude of the
unknown signal vector x since we are
preserving only the science of the
linear measurements
and the other goal in this setting is to
recover the support of the unknown
signal vector x
and in this paper we'll look at support
recovery in the one bit compare sensing
setting
so there are three notions of support
recovery with minimum number of
measurements that we care about in this
paper
the first one is universal exact support
recovery where we want to recover the
support of x exactly from sine of ax
or the observed sine vector
and the designed measurement matrix must
be universal that it should work for all
n dimensional vectors with sparsity at
most k
the second notion of support recovery
that we care about is universal epsilon
approximate support recovery but
we do not want to recover the support
exactly and it is fine if we recover a
set s
from the observed sine vector
sine of ax
such that the size of s is at most k
but
we can allow at most epsilon k false
negatives that is s can contain
[Music]
um
that is f sorry uh s can contain at most
epsilon k false negatives and at most
epsilon give false positives
that is s can contain at most epsilon k
indices which do not actually belong to
the support of x
and there can be epsilon k indices
belongs to the support of x but is not
there in s
so mathematically we want to return s as
the size of s is at most k and the size
of s at minus support of x is at most
epsilon k
and the size of s intersection support
of x is at least max of
0 and the l0 norm of x minus epsilon k
and the final notion of support recovery
is a superset recovery where our goal is
to recover a set s
from the observed sign vector y or sine
of ax
but now we only allow epsilon k false
negatives
we do not false positives we do not
allow false negatives
that is the support of x must be a
subset of the set s that we return
and the size of the set s that we return
can be at most the l zero norm of x plus
epsilon key
so let us briefly discuss our results
for this problem
so first of all for exact support
recovery
acharya
showed that o of k square log n
measurements are sufficient for a
universal scheme for support recovery
and they also prove the lower bound
which showing that the result is
nearly tight
and
if it is additionally known that the
unknown signal vector x is binary
then
it turns out that o of k to the power 3
over 2 log n over k measurements are
sufficient
to reconstruct the binary vector this
was also shown in ajar jatel
so first of all for exact support
recovery in our paper we show that o of
k square log n over k measurements are
sufficient if it is additionally known
that the dynamic range of the unknown
signal vector can be bounded from above
the dynamic
range of the signal vector is the ratio
of the maximum and the minimum magnitude
of the entries of the unknown signal
vector so if it if an upper bound on
this dynamic range is known beforehand
then we can gain some slight improvement
in the number of measurements from the
general case
for epsilon approximate support recovery
we can show that o of k over epsilon log
and our key measurements
are
sufficient
for a universal scheme for approximate
support recovery and we can also
show a nearly matching
lower bound proving that our measurement
complexity for approximate support
recovery is nearly tight
again if we know a upper bound on the
dynamic range of the unknown signal
vector then we can gain some improvement
and if the unknown signal vector x is
known to be binary then it turns out
that o of k over square root of epsilon
log n measurements are sufficient to
reconstruct the binary reconstruct an
approximate support of the binary vector
x
next for superset recovery
we show a sufficient measurement
complexity of over k to the power 3 over
2
divided by square root of epsilon log n
over k
now note that there is a gap of square
root of k factor between the
sufficient measurement complexity and
the necessary measurement complexity in
this in this problem and it is an open
question on how to close this gap
between the
upper bound and the lower bound
it turns out that if we know an upper
bound on the dynamic range of the
unknown signal vector then this gap can
be closed and again if the
unknown signal vector is known to be
binary then this gap can again be closed
but this gap is still exists
for the general problem
okay so if you're aware of group testing
then
we can immediately find many parallels
between group testing and one bit
compressed sensing
so in group testing we have an unknown
signal vector
whose entries can only be zero or one
and again we have a measurement matrix
whose entries are 0 and 1 but this time
the operation between the measurement
matrix and the unknown signal vector is
a logical or operation
so for each measurement
of the unknown signal vector we observe
a one if the support of the measurement
vector contains any
a1 in the signal vector and we observe a
zero if the support of the measurement
and vector contains
does not contain any one from the
unknown signal vector
so for this group testing problem again
k square log n measurements are
sufficient for exact support recovery
but
for
superset recovery it turns out that key
login measurements are sufficient
however it is difficult to replicate
this result for one bit compressed
sensing setting despite the parallels
between the two problems
and the main reason for this is that an
observation of zero in the group testing
setting means that all the indices of
the signal in the support of the
measurement vector is zero
however this is not true for one bit
compress sensing where an observation of
zero simply means that the measurement
vector and the unknown signal vector is
orthogonal
one option is to
have key additional measurements so that
we can form a linearly independent and
matrix
is to truly understand whether
whether there exists any
one in the unknown signal vector in the
support of the measurement
and vector
but this will create an additional
multiplicative k factor
which is undesirable
so now let us move on to our techniques
so first of all we introduce an
interesting combinatorial structure that
we call a list union free family or
matrix
and in this met this matrix has a very
nice property if we take any two sets of
columns s and t of small enough sizes
then there exists some column in the set
s
such that the support of the
column
support of this blue column has small
intersection
with the support of all the
yellow columns
combined in s and d
so we will use this property crucially
so now suppose we have an unknown signal
vector x1 x2 xn which is sparse and has
at most k nonzero entries
now we what we can do is for every
index
j
oh so first of all we use the
measurement matrix to be the list union
free family or list union free matrix
now for reconstruction for
every index j we look at the
intersection of the jth column
of the measurement matrix
support of the jth column of the
measurement matrix and the support of
the output
and we infer
that if this intersection is large then
the index j lies in the support
and if the intersection is small then
the index j does not lie in the support
and we can prove that if we take
a small group of indices that all lie in
the support of the signal vector x and
one of them
must satisfy
this property that is we can correctly
identify one of them is lying in the
support
on the other hand if we take a small
group of indices that does not lie in
the support of x then we can correctly
identify one of them
and this means that we can
the we can suffer at most epsilon k only
a small number of false positives and a
small number of false negatives
now let us move on to superset recovery
here we use another matrix which is
which we call a list strength matrix and
is very popular in the group testing
in literature
here again if we take two subsets of
columns
of small enough sizes s and d then there
exists a blue column in s such that
its support is not contained
within the support of the yellow columns
of t
okay so it means that there exists a row
in this matrix
where
there exists a nonzero entry in this
blue column but
zero entries in all the columns of t
so recall that approximate support
recovery returns the support with a few
false positives and a few false
negatives and for superset recovery
we need to correct
the false
negatives okay we do not want any false
negative such as support of
the unknown signal vector must lie
within the
his subset that we returned
note that for each we can use the least
discharge matrix for superset recovery
in the group testing literature
and therefore if we want to replicate
the result in one bit compressing now we
only need to create s
rows that are linearly independent
here s which is the number of false
negatives is much smaller than k
and this is possible if we ignore this
if we ignore the set of support
that is returned by using the
approximate support recovery
module
now if we correctly balance the number
of false negatives that is returned by
the approximate support recovery module
and the size of the least distinct
matrix then we obtain the desired
guarantee
now this step of
creating s rows that are linearly
independent that works for all sets of
subsets of indices of size k
size s actually
is a bit tricky
what we can do is to replace the ones by
powers of x
so that
the inner product
will create a polynomial whose
coefficients are false
are the false negatives of the unknown
signal vector
and since they are at most s
false negative such a polynomial will
have at most s roots
because the number of coefficients is at
most s
now if additional side information is
known for example if an upper bound on
the dynamic range is
is known or if the number of indices of
same sign is known then we can
do much better and as we showed we can
close the gap between the upper bound
and the lower bound on the measurement
complexity
thank you and please feel free to ask me
any questions on this problem
i'm looking forward to meeting you at
the conference although virtually